i am socks i never wear pants but
suddenly it feels weird to not be
wearing pants are you ready for another
space adventure light you deliver some
of the best voice cast pixar has to
offer and all we can say is to infinity
and beyond we're taking you along the
cast's adventure behind the mic and why
they're just the best fit for these
characters
number one chris evans shines as buzz
lightyear in pixar's new sci-fi film and
he's really got that voice down we're
space rangers we finish the mission you
think he's one of those veteran voice
actors however this actually is his
first time starring in an animated
feature as we all know evans is usually
used in front of the camera with a
shield and aliens flying around but he
does have some voice work buried in his
resume most prominently in the video
game genre what a ride the original
fantastic four may be a little too old
for some of you to remember we feel so
old saying that wow but after its
success chris was asked to lend his
voice to the super fun fantastic 4 video
game you can tell he seemed a little
uncomfortable there but years later he
returned to the booth yet again only
this time voicing another marvel
superhero in captain america super
soldier as for his experience in the
booth for light year he may have been a
little too nervous but he had all the
help he could get from director angus
mclean this role is quite a touchy one
though he had to make the original
version of the original toy version made
iconic by tim allen chris followed a
thin line with his interpretation saying
you have to use what tim allen did it's
not like playing batman where even
though someone else has done it you're
gonna make your own fresh tracks in the
snow
number two every good hero needs a
reliable first mate to infinity
uzo aduba was more than ready to fill
the shoes of alicia hawthorne and had a
hilarious time doing so in the process
all the adults would probably know a
duba from her off-putting character
crazy eyes from netflix's orange is the
new black every actor has got their
ranges so of course the kids would
recognize her as the voice of bismuth
from steven universe she may have just
fallen head over heels for alicia
because she's really always the one
keeping the cast in check are you
willing to lose another four years and
that moment she calls out buzz for his
self narration just screams the perfect
uzo character omg number three sometimes
you need someone to give you a big
reality check and buzz really needs one
a lot there seems to be no sign of
intelligent life anyway chris evans
really seemed to get a kick out of this
moment he cannot help but laugh at the
big ego of buzz at the beginning of his
journey it's not a strange thing for
evans to crack up on set in fact he's
probably done it more than others
but we never really thought about a
voice actor corpsing during a scene so
there you go we guess it can happen just
as much in the booth this moment made
him laugh so hard that it appears he may
have lost his bearings a little we're
always in it for these moments behind
the mic
number four it seems light year made its
way across generations with the story
introducing alicia hawthorne's
granddaughter izzy hawthorne into buzz's
journey kiki palmer snagged the role and
oh was she excited for it i was so
excited to jump in that world as a fan
and as an actor she's always been a big
fan of the pixar universe becoming
obsessed with buzz since toy story like
some of the other cast kiki's got a firm
grasp on the whole voice acting thing
she's been in quite a few animations
from the cleveland show to ice age
that's a pretty big range of characters
and quite the foundation for her big
role in light year
number five things can get intense i'm
buzzed right here i'm always sure not
only for the audience but apparently for
the cast as well evans really goes all
in at the booth really giving everything
he's got to this line we get it as an
actor you really gotta back up that
intense moment with a little physicality
you can really see the veins bulging
from his head and neck yikes we hope he
took a little breather after this moment
number six we've got to see a lot of
taika waititi he keeps himself busy
directing and now apparently voice
acting well this is pretty cool he's
really just got the perfect voice for
cartoons which is why he was the perfect
choice for moe morrison this big time
director has won a lot of awards for his
work including best adapted screenplay
at the oscars like much of the
well-established cast taika had a lot of
other projects in the works while
recording for light year the much
anticipated thor sequel thor love and
thunder was underway so we can't imagine
balancing all that creativity but he's
apparently one of those busy creatives
always working hard to satisfy that
craving yeah it's just a different style
of acting his spirit lives on in mo
taika being a dedicated team member and
all but morrison's clumsiness maybe or
maybe not we don't make judgments here
number seven what an unlikely buzz
companion socks is sox is both butler
that was there to help but also a good
friend to listen not only is it adorable
to see a robotic cat fight aliens but it
also has a super cool actor giving it a
voice some may not recognize the name
peter son but when you take a look at
some of the projects he's done you'll
see he's been behind the scenes of some
of our favorite childhood classics he's
a huge staple in the pixar community
doing everything from animating to
lending his voice starting with the
iconic finding nemo he's been in pretty
much all of their films since we're so
glad he's given a chance to shine in
lightyear even if he's just chasing
lasers in this one
number eight an all-time american
classic everyone ramirez should have won
an oscar for his performance as pedro in
napoleon dynamite no awards needed he's
just an actor that shows up and gives it
his all in light year he plays
armadillos assisting buzz on his quest
dropping in a few times to add some more
comedic relief which we know he's so
subtly good at though to him it was more
than just being the comedic relief he
had an absolute blast working on the
details of his character and finding his
voice in order to find the voice of a
character is to find what his center was
number nine bring on the boom dale souls
and she brings it to this one with
everything she's got a real no-nonsense
gruff type who can take any three
objects and make them explode before
snacking the role of the wild darby
steel she played the character of frida
berlin in orange is the new black that's
pretty cool she got to team up again
with orange alumni uzo aduba again only
this time she's playing a much different
character like the rest of the cast it
looks like dale had an exhilarating
experience behind the mic in my opinion
they must be very good-hearted people
however she brought something no one
else could a very explosive presence
number 10 isaiah whitlock jr has been
acting in the biz for quite a long time
with a career spanning 40 years he's
decided to add commander burnside to his
repertoire it's fantastic he's not only
a strong presence in front of the camera
but he's made impacts in animation as
well
number 11 talk about flying under the
radar when bill hader was cast as
feathering himself a lot of people were
really not to wear of course bill has
made comedic gold over the past decade
and stepped aside into the dramatic
world of hbo's barry his personality was
used in some of the biggest animated
blockbusters like cloudy with a chance
of meatballs and the fan favorite inside
out we're not really sure why he didn't
do a whole lot of press for this one
however we can't rule out that he was
taking barry a little too seriously and
just imagined in real life that he was
evading his capture
number 12 like father like son the
brolins can play some good evil villains
a little too well coming into this movie
i knew nothing about zorg james brolin
was sworn to secrecy for the role of
zerg so much so that he never knew what
was going to happen until he stepped
into the studio the moment of everything
would be learned on the spot at the
recording sessions writers would
literally hand him the scenes he was
about to record right when he stepped
behind the mic talk about some on the
spot acting they did not want me to blab
about uh who he was this group of space
misfits are destined for greatness and
who knew chris evans could play such a
great tribute to buzz lightyear it's
amazing how random choices in casting
from filmmakers can end up being the
best choices for the roles we'd really
like to know do you think there should
be another sequel let us know in the
comments